I'm Regina Crimp.
Traci Reardon.
I'm Ho Ho.
I'm a naughty elf.
My name is Big Sue I uh firmly believe in
everybody's right to have a slice of pizza
pie.
My name is Todd.
I don't really care if I'm grounded.
My name is Lauren Lapkus and I'm an improvisor
and actor.
So you might know Lauren from her roles in
Orange Is the New Black or Jurassic World.
You might even know her from her own podcast.
I however was introduced to her through the
podcast Comedy Bang Bang where she often improvises
slightly unhinged oddball characters.
On the 377th episode of that podcast, she
and Paul F. Tompkins created one of the most
delightful and weird comedic moments of the
last year.
And it was all completely improvised.
Chazmin: "We used to sleep in a vault."
Scott Aukerman: "Really?"
Sunny: "Yeah that got tight.
Once we started making money!"
Chazmin: "I think that's where we developed
a clausterphobia as well."
Sunny: "Maybe a little!"
Paul F. Tompkins and I played characters named
Chazmin and Sunny and all we decided before
we recorded the episode was that were going
to be radio show hosts together and that we
had this morning talk show.
Chazmin: "I don't know how you feel about
it Sunny!"
Sunny: "The same you know that!"
Chazmin: "Ahhhh that was a trick question."
Sunny: "Razzle dazzle!"
I think characters really spoke to me because
I could be anyone and especially because I
started when I was younger it felt more comfortable
to not play myself and to play something else
and something totally different.
I find voices in my car all the time and one
of the most recent ones I found was Big Sue
who's a she talks like this.
She likes pizza.
Her big thing is pizza.
She's always concerned about getting another
slice.
Uh she describes pizza very in depth even
though we all know what that is.
Uh but finding that voice was really fun for
me cause it's like a new thing that I discovered
I could do.
I definitely feel like I embody characters
as I'm doing a podcast.
A lot of my characters have really absurd
descriptions.
There's one character, I believe if I recall
correctly her eyes were extremely close together
and her butt crack was fused.
I have Pamela from Big Bear who's a meth head.
She's got crazy teeth.
For sure missing some of them.
And then there's Ho Ho the Naughty Elf who's
the size of a dollar bill uh he's a naughty
elf that works in Santa's workshop.
He has a candy cane penis?
Can I say that?
He has a candy cane penis.
He's evil but lovable.
One of the things that gets hard the more
episodes of my podcast I do is finding new
voices.
It's basically impossible.
I've done like 70 episodes now and it's a
different character every time.
So I have Traci Reardon who's a 17 year old
girl she talks like she has a rhotacism which
means she can't say her "r's".
Regina Crimp who she's the singer of The America's
Funniest Home Videos theme song.
Her hair gets bigger it doesn't grow longer.
She sings "We've got lives from coast to coast"
and she talks like this she really is like
she's just happy about life and you know she
lives in her car, sure, she lives in her car.
She uh grills hamburgers on the engine some
nights just to kinda heat em up.
She doesn't have a microwave or anything like
that.
She's pretty sad.
She spent all of her money from her theme
songs uh pretty quickly and now she doesn't
have anything.
When I was in Chicago there was a group called
Ragdolls.
An all female improv group.
They were so amazing and to watch a group
of women just go totally insane together and
follow whatever was saying was completely
and totally support each other was really
inspiring to me.
As I was younger it was a lot harder for me
to start a conversation with a stranger for
instance and I think improv taught me how
to just go with it and now judge myself and
trust that I have something worth saying.
Thanks so much for watching the video.
I'm going to put a couple of links down below
with podcast recommendations for all of Lauren's
characters.
They are all super funny they all had me in
tears by the end I was laughing so hard and
it's really some of the best comedy and improv
you'll ever listen to.